that's Jack Harlow's hit track named
after Dua Lipa and now it seems the
rapper may have manifested doing more
with Dua than a feature with a source
telling E.T they have a good connection
I think I'm playing it cool The Source
opens up about their budding romance
explaining quote Jack and Dua are
hanging out and seeing where things go
he was a fan at first and once he met
her and got to know her he liked her
even more The Source note said Dua is
totally his type and he thinks she's
extremely talented thank you our source
also says that Jack has been pursuing
Dua and is very into her just wait on
her the pair first sparked romance
rumors after they appeared pretty cozy
posing for pics together at variety's
hitmakers brunch earlier this month as
for that song on Jack's most recent
album
well back in May the musician opened up
on The Breakfast Club about getting the
pop star's approval before putting out
the track I wanted to get her blessing I
saw a FaceTime her and played it for it
because I didn't want her to be
Blindside about that or feel like you
know creeped out or anything I want her
to
if she had said yo I hate it I don't
want it to come out it wouldn't have
came out and while Jack admitted she
wasn't totally into it at first she
ultimately gave her blessing ahead of
the album's release she was like oh
I mean it's not my song I suppose it's
okay she was just kind of thrown off and
she just let it go but when the rapper
was asked if he was crushing on Dua he
played koi is that a woman you fancy is
that why you made the record I admire
her it's about her yeah
ET has reached out to both Jack and
dua's Reps for comment of course before
being linked to Jack Dua dated Anwar
Hadid you know Gigi and Bella's younger
bro who's also a fellow model but the
two called it quits last December
meanwhile Jack was linked to Addison Ray
in April 2021 but she quickly shut down
the rumors tweeting at the time I'm
single and he previously revealed his
three celebrity crushes all striking
brunettes like Dua I like uh Alexa Demi
Constance Marie Salma Hayek so it seems
like we'll have to see how things play
out between the two but in the meantime
we have Jack's track to get us through
nothing